hi mom
hi Ann how are you I'm fantastic
yeah well you look great as always you
know what I didn't know and I think the
Dennis would be surprised as you know
your pop culture right you know like the
Kardashians you you you're aware the car
now everybody is okay do you watch the
Kardashians no you do not but you know
who they are
oh you got a problem with them well no
oh you would okay so that's just like
later you can tell me how you feel yeah
what about and you do watch a lot of
sports people should know that sports is
always on the house
your big Reds fan and Bengals fan wait
not a Reds fan anymore they need a new
leader
there you go breaking news my mom calls
out Reds management okay say you're not
watching the Reds anymore I Bengals did
you like Carson Palmer when he was the
quarterback of the Vale you did not know
why not
he was always I better not say that
either Oh
my mom says Bengals wasted draft pick on
Carson Palmer yeah he seems like a nice
guy when we've had well he's done well
since he left
but do you hold a grudge against him for
leaving the bangle yeah you're okay yeah
what about the Ohio State Buckeyes
yeah you like the book guys yeah and
Notre Dame football so what else you got
well I don't know I was just looking for
you know your opinions here on things
what Jim what are we talking about well
we were talking about Kardashians you
got pinning on Beyonce oh you're not
allowed to say these opinions well I
don't want you to get in trouble
oh I don't what I get in trouble for
what you think about the Kardashians or
Beyonce I would I think so huh so when
we go to lunch after the show we can
discuss whoa I like that
yes bully we have some questions for
your mommy no okay when Dan was young
and did he want to play grade school
football and did you have any
reservations about it back then
he just wanted to play any kind of sport
that had a ball connection to him I'm
just a good football player what about
his academic skills as youth he but the
nuns thought he was a pain because
everything had to be perfect
he couldn't even write his name to suit
him and he had wads of paper around his
desk on the floor I never finished my
assignment because I didn't even like
how I sign my name it wasn't perfect so
then they gave me a garbage can right by
my desk yeah and then I would just be
filled and everybody else would finish
their assignment mine would I didn't get
my name written yeah couple more
questions from Dan that's when his
childhood bedroom did he collect tons
and tons of stuff so much so that you
could barely move
I just got that idea out of nowhere out
of nowhere a studio they leave me it was
top on the list they didn't constantly
reorganize the stuff in his room they
call me a hoarder
that fair yeah I collect everything I go
to basketball games that's when you know
we had basketball Cincinnati Royals yeah
and bring him home I'm on the wall some
wonder the wall was still standing
because there's they'd stick and you
tried to take him on oh well I remember
that like the Lakers came to town and
you would there would be the Lakers
sticker on the floor and it was huge it
was bigger than it was about size my
desk so it would be on the floor during
the game and then I would go over and
say can I have that so they give me the
sticker off the floor I'd somehow get it
home and put it on my bedroom wall
and I had the I had the Baltimore
bullets back then I am the Atlanta Hawks
and I had the LA Lakers with their Logan
my room wasn't big right it was sort of
like a prison cell and I shared it with
my younger brother right that was a
pretty small bedroom and they didn't
have anything you like on the wall yeah
I had everything yeah and then the cold
air shaft
yeah yes we love it so in Dan was a kid
were his friends
more cool guys or nerds
he's now his friends are total nerds we
know that oh is he part of the cool
crowd or sort of the nerdy crowd who
ever wanted to play ball didn't make a
difference I didn't judge is what she's
saying I just accepted everybody for who
they were again across the street kept
the light on in his yard and he built a
big cement area so they can play
basketball up till midnight yeah did he
hire those guys to laugh at his jokes he
couldn't find anybody
I hired four guys over there and I might
be hiring four new guys
now how funny is any other yes Fritzi
how concerned were you that Dan wasn't
going to amount to anything growing up
and if he wasn't a sports broadcaster
what would he be doing for a living oh
let's see
he'd like to sing he'd sing all the time
I don't know that he I didn't have a
plan B mom no I didn't have a fallback
plan he just knew where he was going
yeah and I there were some struggles
along the way let's not kid anybody you
know my grades yeah yeah that was your
fault
yes I know because he's a very good
student you were gonna say bright you
can say have it's gonna say right you
know yeah very bright not very bright
but you were bright bright and you were
a good student when you put your mind
yes but I never did know because I had
other more important things like hot
chicks and basketball in that order
right
I'd go taste in women back then right
did they always like time here no I'm
glad you stopped by and I hope we you
guys give me a great birthday this
weekend that'd be nice no it's called
the end of the show yeah yeah so I gotta
say hi to my friends yeah of course you
do
shout out did you want to give me their
names all right well you can you can
start give me a couple of them to say
hello to you got like Trudy Pringle and
of course
yeah mem Williams yeah okay anybody
that's all the time we've got
yep that'll do it yeah I thought I'd be
on longer than we're going down to the
bar so oh okay yeah
well I only got a little shot
month the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience